the jurgen experience you're not better
than other people because you think a
certain way there's so many people that
are like
i'm right obviously and you're wrong
obviously and it's like that's not how
things work
and with all the canceling all the
twitter stuff they're going pas like
down this line of which now we've given
them with twitter right
you're just giving people a transcript
of like all the [ __ ] you've said over
the years
but it's like you're expected to have
this perfect record like you're never
supposed to
we're flawed humans that's how we learn
that's how we learn that's how we grow
it's through adversity we learn
we [ __ ] up we fail we get back up and
there's no room for that anymore but
it's also here's the thing like
why are you spending so much time
complaining about other people all day
i'll tell you why because you're not
healthy that's right you're not
doing smart things if i look at your
twitter timeline and i'm seeing tweets
12 hours a day you're a crazy person
yeah you might not realize you're a
crazy person you think there'll be a day
where
we will look back and go remember when
anyone could get on twitter at
any time you think there's going to be
like like smoking there's going to be
like restrictions
i think twitter is going to be like
blockbuster video i think we're going to
look back remember when we used to
communicate through twitter
like oh my god it was so toxic everybody
was so mean we're going to hit some new
thing
next that's going to allow people to
read each other's minds or
elon musk's neural link which he's
talking about communicating with no
words
we're going to hit that and it's going
to make this seem like nonsense
yeah because we're we're lacking in this
is one of the things that
in that book irresistible there's
there's no empathy in these
conversations and that's the big part of
the problem it's like you don't see the
people you don't feel their pain
so you could say horrible [ __ ] to them
it's the
vast majority of the way people are
communicating like a lot of people
the vast majority of their communication
is text messages right
and tweets and none of it is person to
person like these kids are arguing with
each other
through text because they don't want to
look at each other and talk like human
beings ironically that's the only way
you develop and grow as a person
[Applause]